l'assaut des bas d'europe me dit
maintenant avec bruno myle yens député
modem des yvelines bonjour
et sébastien jumel députés communistes
nul de seine-maritime bonjour bonjour
alors le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin est attendu en corse tout à
l'heure une nouvelle séquence politique
et diplomatique pour le ministre hier il
s'exprimait sur les rodéos urbains il
était à créteil il a revendiqué plus de
2000 contrôles en une semaine la semaine
dernière il promettait déjà dit mille
contrôle policier pour mettre fin ce
phénomène de plus en plus répandue avant
thierry parlait de trois contrôles par
jour ça fait beaucoup de chiffres et est
ce que c'est le retour de la politique
du cif bono billien
du chiffre parce que ces
chiffres sous nicolas sarkozy
on mettait des mains courantes voilà on
ne faisait pas d' enquête on mettait des
quelles mains courantes donc on n'avait
pas de pain donc ça c'est toute la
politique du chiffre là on va vraiment
chercher effectivement les fauteurs de
trouble ont permis ce qui annonce des
chiffres qui sont réelles qu un ministre
qui se contentent de main courante
sébastien jumel ça vous rappelle nicolas
sarkozy tous ces chiffres égrainé
semaine après semaine par gérald
darmanin ces chiffres ses objectifs même
oui gérald darmanin c'est le canada dry
de sarkozy réinventer les mêmes postures
le même vocabulaire les mêmes objectifs
peut-être avec les moyens
d'intervention en moins moi ce que je
constate c'est que l'on ne découvre pas
l'horreur qui représentait rodéo ou
urbain à la faveur de l'été c'est
malheureusement un fait ancien connu un
marqueur identitaire chez certains
jeunes désoeuvrés que ça implique au
contraire des moyens durables
de police de proximité
de moyens pour la prévention spécialisée
dans les
territoires concernés moi j'ai l'exemple
en tête là un maire de l'oise me disais
pour répondre aux objectifs des coûts du
mini d'intérieur on va faire un contrôle
à 16h dans sa commune comme si l'heureux
deux aux urbains avaient lieu à cette
heure-ci dans les communes concernées
n'ont que des chiffres mais au bout du
compte pas véritablement de moyens
police de proximité j'ai en veut pour
preuve dans mon territoire où la
population triple pendant l'été à diamou
verront difficilement les moyens pour
constituer une équipe de nuit
permettant aux policiers d'assurer
convenablement leurs missions de
sécurité à laquelle je tiens parce que
le droit à la sécurité est un droit
fondamental
bruno myle yen il y aller les objectifs
les chiffres et puis aussi les images
très nombreuses il suffit d'aller sur
les réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce qui on peut faire encore pour
durcir le ton contre ces rodéos à moto
de plus en plus dangereux et encore eu
un mort à marseille lundi soir
les rôdeurs
ne découvre pas la
démocratie depuis un certain nombre
d'années qui s'étend parle effectivement
eu deux jeunes un peu un peu désoeuvrés
il ya des réponses judiciaires plus
importante qu'il faudrait peut-être
année parce qu'aujourd'hui on en est un
la saisie des véhicules quand on peut la
saisir vous savez c'est très compliqué
de 2,2 pour chasser des gens qui font du
rodéo urbain qu'est ce que c'est
dangereux non seulement pour ceux qui le
font perdre et l'allemagne à des dangers
d'accidents graves il ya des mises mise
en danger aussi le naufrage novaïa mise
en danger des gens qui sont autour donc
c'est une affaire à prendre très au
sérieux on peut pas juste se dire mais
il ya qu à les arrêter c'est pas aussi
simple que ça
une fois qu'on les a arrêtés la saisie
du véhicule est importante et surtout il
faut garder ce véhicule le temps qu'une
enquête aboutisse et après il ya la
réponse judiciaire qui est pas forcément
toujours à la hauteur alors son aide
dans le tout répressif mais je sais que
dans certains pays et n'a la réponse
judiciaire tanner jusqu'à la destruction
du véhicule vous savez moi j'ai constaté
sur mon territoire que c'était très
simple pour eux finalement de continuer
à faire des rodéos urbains ne prenez
jamais votre propre véhicule ou le
prêter un copain nous notre copain près
de son véhicule à un autre et c est au
moment où on doit remettre le véhicule
et dernier vrai propriétaire vient le
chercher et vous n'avez rien prévu dont
il repart avec son véhicule et ça
continue pour ça il faut quand même
qu'on travaille un petit peu lâché
sébastien jumel
la loi de 2010 8e a fait d'heureux d'eau
urbains un délit donc une simple
infraction donc la question risque quand
même cinq entreprises rome ouais la
question juridique a été abordé par le
législateurs la question c'est les
moyens pour la mettre en oeuvre les
moyens de la justice les moyens de la
police et puis les moyens de la
prévention spécialisée parce que dans
les fêtes on n'en prend pas la moto d'un
copain on le vole et donc au bout du
compte cliquez sur la propriété du bien
n'est pas n'est pas le sujet et puis il
faudrait être aux côtés des maires au
quotidien dans les moyens qu'on les
maires de mener des opérations de
prévention de la délinquance à la faveur
de l'été en renforçant les moyens de la
politique de la vie' c'est aussi un
angle mort du discours de la première
ministre lors de son intervention mme
pelletier général voilà c'est un premier
tour de table sont les rodéos urbains
mais aussi l'offensive
médiatico politique de gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur qui était à
créteil hier il arrive en corse tout à
l'heure pour évoquer donc c'est c c'est
dramatique
orages qui ont déjà fait au moins trois
morts ce matin gérald darmanin qu'on a
également vu sur le terrain de
l'immigration il a annoncé un grand
débat à l'assemblée en octobre prochain
sur les feux il était dans le jura hier
il a également beaucoup parlé du cas de
l'imam if you scène et pendant ce temps
le président emmanuel macron est bien
silencieux on ne l'a pas entendu de
l'été il a raison d'être silencieux
bruno myle jens et sa nouvelle méthode
laisser faire le ministre de l'intérieur
je ne sais pas si ces nouvelles méthodes
de laisser faire les intérieurs mise à
l'intérieur et du travail j'ai les
événements de cet été fait normal qu'il
se déplace on a connu d'ailleurs plus
discret oui bah écoutez c'est comme ça
quant au président de la république je
pense qu'ils goûtent des vacances
méritées comme tout un chacun et voilà
il n'a pas pour autant laissé tomber les
stylos les décrets ont été signés des
lois qu'on a voté gtt il s'est entretenu
à l'international beaucoup et notamment
avec des lances qui voit là il continue
à travailler le plus grand son et mais
il n'y a pas de déclaration particulière
à faire sébastien jumel
emmanuel macron est trop discret sur il
ya une posture je pense que le prix en
république on sert que sa parole est
d'or et le se cache derrière les
gesticulations de ces différents
ministres moi j'espère que pendant que
les français n'ont pas le loisir de
partir en vacances il aura quand même
pris quelques devoirs de vacances le
président de la république moi je suis
préoccupé à la rentrée par plusieurs
sujets sains l'état de santé l'état de
l'hôpital qui tient à bout de bras grâce
à la mobilisation de la communauté
hospitalière mais dont on n'a rien réglé
en termes de moyens d'attractivité et de
nécessiter de réarmer l'hôpital public
et je parle pas de la médecine de ville
qui les déserts médicaux continue
d'avancer d'une manière préoccupante je
suis inquiète des conditions de la
rentrée scolaire parce que l'ascenseur
social de l'école de la république est
en panne
monsieur blanquaert à mais beaucoup abus
mais l'école à travers les différentes
réformes et je constate que le nouveau
ministre
a enfilé les chaussons de son
prédécesseur et n'est pas en situation
de lutter contre le rabot budgétaire qui
percute l'école de la maternelle jusqu'à
l'université
notamment j'ai beaucoup d'exemples de
collège qui sont à la peine pour
préparer la rentrée scolaire et moi
j'espère que donc ces questions là
seront au coeur
de la rentrée
de même l'uppercut du pouvoir d'achat
dont la loi votée pendant l'été ne
réparera pas va rester la préoccupation
numéro un des français les coûts de
rentrée scolaire explose pour les
familles les problématiques de coûts de
l'énergie
font mal au porte-monnaie de la france
qui travaille donc j'espère que le
discours du 14 juillet qui était un
virage à droite confirmée les président
des riches permettra emmanuel macron de
mettre son silence de vacances à profit
pour corriger la copie voilà emmanuel
battre qu'on devrait entendre demain il
doit participer à la cérémonie des
soixante dix huit ans de la libération
de bormes les mimosas lé cérémonie a été
en raison de la météo reporté à demain
alors vous évoquiez sébastien jumel fou
de 42 à dieppe en ce moment avec un bel
hommage à nos amis canadiens sébastien
jumel vous évoquiez la rentrée la loi
pouvoir d'achat également j'aimerais
évoquer cette polémique est en train de
monter puis une semaine cette
proposition de loi élaborée par le party
les républicains visant à mieux
contrôler la rs l'aide de rentrée
scolaire qui a été revalorisée de 2 4%
c'est une proposition de loi qui est
signé par l'actuelle présidente et l'air
par intérim annie genevard et l'objectif
c'est d'encadrer l'utilisation de cette
allocation
s'assurer qu'elles soient bien dépensés
dans des fournitures scolaires la
proposition de loi est également signée
député pierre henri dumont on garde la
même somme on la divise en deux la
première partie est donnée aux communes
pour qu'elles puissent acheter des trous
sont selon les besoins des enseignants
c'est à dire que ray des cahiers des
stylos bref tout ce qui est pas
personnalisable le reste la moitié de la
somme est versée directement aux
familles en bons d'achat chez tous les
commerçants partenaires et où là on peut
acheter tout ce qui est personnalisable
des cartables des thrombus des vêtements
des affaires de sport on peut s'inscrire
dans les activités culturelles et
sportives et donc ça permet vraiment
concrètement un pouvoir faire des
économies deux d'avoir plus de matériel
pour les enfants 3 de s'assurer que
l'argent de la société nationale va à la
réussite des enfants exclusivement à la
réussite des enfants c'est là je pense
un bel objectif et ça permet de rassurer
les français sur leur consentement à
l'impôt voilà la rs et est versée en
cette fin août à de nombreuses familles
et dans le dans le besoin le montant
minimal c'est 360 16,98 euros pour des
enfants âgés de 6 à 10 ans
397 pour un enfant âgé de 11 à 14 ans à
monter jusqu'à 4 111 euros pour les
enfants âgés de 15 à 18 ans alors cette
proposition de loi fait bondir la gauche
mais aussi une partie de la majorité
présidentielle notamment le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
olivier ferrand qui parle d'une
stigmatisation des foyers modestes
bruno myle yens vous êtes d'accord aussi
il ya de la stigmatisation moi je pense
qu'il faut que les républicains mais de
proposition de loi qui effectivement ce
qui m attire les gens
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
franchement si la société a été le sien
elle pouvait faire plus geoffrey je ne
crois pas que la majorité des parents
qui reçoit cette allocation la dépense à
autre chose que pour leurs enfants faut
arrêter maintenant cessé de la
droitisation
les républicains qui me paraît
complètement hors de propos hors norme
et si d'aventuré on vient à l'étude et à
l'assemblée nationale je pense que je
m'y opposerai de toutes mes forces ça
rappelle un peu aussi à l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer redon issus de votre
majorité bruno billien il suggérait l'an
dernier une allocation par bons d'achat
pour je cite
que les familles ne s'achète pas avec la
rs
s'il vous plaît faut arrêter avec ça
qu'on travaille sérieusement sur sur la
solidarité à la source dans lesquelles
renault près toutes les allocations et
on permettrait à tout le monde notamment
ceux qui ne donnent pas recours à leur
droit à certaines allocations de les
recevoir directement face à me paraît
quelque chose d'équitable et éthiques
voilà et qu'on arrête avec ça parce que
effectivement c'est la stigmatisation de
gens qui n'ont pas besoin de
climatisation jeu franchement sortir une
polémique comme ça au mieux des tj
trouve ça assez ridicule sébastien jumel
moi c'est indécent parce que ce faisant
la droite
permet qu'on fasse les skiffs sur la
nécessaire débat du manque de
l'insuffisance de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire qui ne couvrent pas les
besoins réels des familles et qui nous
couvre pas ce que représente l'inflation
en matière de rentrées scolaires et puis
c'est indécent parce que ceux qui
proposent ça sont les mêmes qui ferme
les yeux lorsque la france d'en haut
continue de faire du pognon en dormant
enseignant la france d'en bas moi j'ai
été maire pendant dix ans d'une belle
ville qui s'appelle dit à poux on a mis
en place des fournitures dans des écoles
maternelles et les écoles élémentaires
mais l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
vise à complémenter ça à permettre aux
familles qui se saignent aux quatre
veines et y compris ceux qui bossent
avec des petits salaires et bien que
leurs enfants soient convenablement à
billets pour aller à l'école soit
correctement équipés pour pratiquer une
activité sportive et moi je connais peu
de parents qui ne sont pas préoccupés
par le bien être de leurs enfants donc
ce sont des mesures dilatoires de
diversion qui font l'impasse sur au
contraire le besoin d'être au chevet
de ceux qui se lèvent le matin et qui
ont le sentiment que la vie est plus
dure est au chevet des familles les plus
fragiles et les plus modestes ajoute que
le coc vide que nous avons traversées à
démontrer que la jeunesse a pris cher de
la jeunesse a été percuté par cette
crise sans précédent que nous avons
traversée on manque de médecins
scolaires on manque d'accompagnement
psychologique on manque de moyens
humains pour prendre en charge les
enfants en situation de handicap dans
les écoles on manque de statut pour les
personnels aes âge et que c'est plutôt
de cela dont j'aimerais parler lorsqu'il
s'agit de mettre en place l'état qui
prend soin la droite les libéraux sont
pour l'état qui accentue les inégalités
de mon époux l'état qui prend seront
alors à la rentrée la majorité le
président souhaite organiser le conseil
national de la refondation se serait en
principe pour la deuxième semaine de
septembre
la nuque en tout cas la france a soumise
à d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'elle n'y
participerait pas ce sera la même chose
pour le parti communiste français
sébastien jumel parce qu'on parlera en
principe de santé d'éducation
écoutez n'est pas le général de gaulle
qui veut
savait il ne vous a pas échappé que cet
intitulé visa s'inspirait du conseil
national de la résistance
mais qu'at on a là aussi
l'apparence mais que le compte n'y est
pas puisque dans son discours du 14
juillet le président la république a
confirmé vouloir continuer à s'attaquer
aux retraites vouloir continuer à
s'attaquer à l'assurance maladie vouloir
mettre en place l'austérité généralisée
avec le retour de la règle des 3% de
déficit public et donc il est d'accord
pour qu'on discute tous ensemble à
travers des règles et des résultats et
des conclusions qu'il aura rédigé à
l'avancé nous on va occuper tout ne
place à l'assemblée on va demander à ce
que ces sujets là soit débattu d'une
manière démocratique dans ce qui est le
chaudron de la démocratie l'assemblée
nationale et on aura des propositions à
formuler pour réarmer la santé pour
réarmer l'école pour redonner du sens
aux services publics de proximité
pourrait infirmer la présence de la
république présente partout les pour
tous et que créer des instances or des
instances prévues par la démocratie
c'est une manière de contourner la
démocratie donc nous assumerons notre
rôle d'opposant mais nous continuerons à
être force de proposition pour améliorer
la vie des français cesse à l'adn des
communistes au sein du rassemblement de
la nuit le bruit domitienne sévère
concurrence le parlement non je veux
dire un modèle filles jumelles que
évidemment je vois pas les choses comme
ça donc être d'accord sur certains
points où deux légers tout à l'heure
mais avoir avoir des gens qui ce qu'ils
se rencontrent aussi au sénat car
effectivement l'acronyme ne vous plaît
pas ça j'ai bien compris d'avoir des
jambes et spécialistes qui peuvent se
manger aussi bien sur les questions sans
quelques sur les questions d'éducation
nationale et qui peuvent peut-être
effectivement aboutir à des propositions
de loi ou on n'aurait pas toujours la
force restera à la loi et au parlement
et on en débattra d'ailleurs la nouvelle
configuration du parlement fait qu'on va
beaucoup plus débattre qu'on n'a jamais
débattu sur la vème république
donc voilà il faut pas il faut pas
s'inquiéter
quand le président voyait mais c'est que
j'étais à bourgtheroulde comme président
de la république a lancé le grand débat
dont j'avais d'ailleurs dénoncée à
l'avance le petit disions nous fondions
dans cette démocratie rien inventé et le
grand débat s'est transformé en grand de
manipulation c'est à dire que la
convention citoyenne n'a pas été suivi
dans ses préconisations les maires qui
ont foncé
prennent ce que la commune reste reste
pour réponse du gouvernement est donc
les machins comme on dit créé pour
contourner
la démocratie et pour amuser l'opinion
publique ça ne marche pas nous avons
besoin de réponses d'urgence pour
l'école pour l'emploi pour la jeunesse
pour notre industrie pour préserver
notre souveraineté alimentaire moi je
suis très préoccupé en ce moment du sort
de nos agriculteurs producteurs de lait
je suis profondément préoccupé de la
manière dont la france abandonne ses
pêcheurs sur le littoral français et
donc c'est de ces sujets concrets que le
parlement dont le parlement doit se
saisir pour apporter des réponses
rapides urgente et en changeant la donne
après qu'on multiplie les occasions de
consulter les corps constitués les
organisations syndicales des
associations qui depuis de longues
années ont des propositions à formuler
eh bien je lui dire que les forces vives
qui réfléchissent à ces sujets là depuis
longtemps existe en france et il faut au
contraire les respecter parce qu'elles
ont une légitimité des syndicats ont
prévu
vous allez pouvoir et place et bastien
jumelles après une courte pause
sébastien jumel députés communistes
n'eut pts de seine maritime et bruno
myle yens député modem des yvelines
bruno myle yens vous vouliez répondre à
votre collègue communiste qui est
qualifié le cnr le conseil national de
refondateurs prévue à la rentrée
de d'objets d'amusement si j'ai bien
compris
c'est par pure opposition et c'est
dommage si on reprend le grand débat
national
je suis désolé ça à coucher déjà sur des
mesures question que tu as quand même 17
milliards mais mesures de soutien gilet
jaune sur cette première chose moi j'en
ai fait 16 des grands débats sur mon
territoire sans permis aussi de
débloquer d'expliquer des situations que
les gens ne comprenaient pas ou avait
mal perçu donc ça certes et toutes
façons à quelque chose pour le pôle la
loi climat et résidences issue la
convention citoyenne il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont il ya des
mesures qui étaient proposés par les
citoyens qui étaient des mesures qui
relèvent de l'europe des packs de la
france parce que sur les met en place en
france ça ne sert à rien il y avait des
mesures qui était réglementaire et les
autres on les a traités alors peut-être
pas à ce qu espère éventuellement
certains mais tout a été traitée à part
les trois points que le président avait
dit le syndicat unia venez un joker donc
moi je veux bien pas on se pose à tous
par opposition mais il ya des moments
ils font reconnaître aussi les choses et
ce conseil national de la refondation on
verra bien ce que ça donne moi je trouve
pas inintéressant et d'ailleurs les
corps constitués les associations les
organisations syndicales sont invités à
y participer
s'il ne trouve pas inintéressant qu'ils
donnent leur avis voilà après tout
passera évidemment par le parlement et
avec le nouvel la nouvelle chambre
parlementaire attend 17 h unis avec la
nouvelle chambre parlementaire forcément
il y aura des débats il y aura de bons
débats j'en suis persuadé sébastien
jumel vous avez vu le le iop sémantique
qui représente l'utilisation du site le
cnr à la libérale dans la laissant dans
le sang et les larmes de la résistance
et de la libération
ceux qui avaient résisté à l'oppresseur
nazis ont posé les jalons de l'état qui
protège
le renouveau industriel là on a un bloc
de celui qui envisage de continuer à des
manques c'est la protection sociale à la
française avec les attaques prévues
contre l'assurance chômage qui s'apprête
à revenir avec son mauvais projet des
réformes des retraites donc de cnr il ne
reste évidemment que l'acronyme moi
j'étais
je suis
je non mais on ne refusera pas le débat
on viendra un porteur de propositions à
l'assemblée
je les dis très clairement sur l'hôpital
et les déserts médicaux sur la nécessité
de redonner à l'école de la république
son rôle d'ascenseur social au service
de tous les enfants sur
l'urgence qu'il y à ce que l'état
travaille à un aménagement équilibré du
territoire avec des services publics
présents partout et pour tous avec la
commune comme pilier de la république
qui prend soin on va venir avec des
propositions pour dessiner à défendre
une france la souveraineté industrielle
la nécessité que les a reconnus soit
reconnu et est donc voila moi je vous
savez
les cabinets conseils lorsque les
cabinets conseils comme mckinsey qui
échappent à l'impôt continue de
conseiller l'elysée il n'y a pas grand
chose à attendre de rares de ces
réformes et j'ajoute que au moment où on
annonce vouloir créer une instance de
consultation sur l'apprentissage les
centres de formation d'apprentis
apprennent qu'ils vont subir et de mardi
portant dans moins de 10 %
à la veille de la rentrée scolaire qui
ont bien sûr la lumière gouvernement
depuis ils le savent depuis 2005 c'est
l'actuel vous savez très bien le sale
depuis 2001 bourse ou fait deux ans
qu'ils le savent et pourquoi c'est
arrivé parce qu'il ya eu des effets
d'aubaine sur certaines formations vous
le savez très bien où le prix des
formations n'est pas en corrélation avec
les subventions de l'état et vous pouvez
pas nous attaquent à seraient des
acteurs nationaux de l'afges regardez
bien les serveurs alors sur certaines
formations où il va falloir qu'on fasse
sur un point mais vous ne pouvez pas
nous taxer d'avoir raté l'apprentissage
on a fait quelques tours fréquentes et
apprentis au cours d'un service
économie à la veille de la rentrée sur
les seize ans mais non on va regarder si
filière par filière on va regarder
filière par filière
ce qu'il est possible de faire ou pas il
ya des filières qui ont joué
malheureusement et vous savez que ça
existe dans ce pays et pas seulement
dans ce secteur mais qui ont joué des
effets d'aubaine voilà et bien ça c'est
normal vous ni date est effectivement
pour que certaines choses reviennent de
manière plus importante aux as du temps
notamment pour la rentrée scolaire vous
devriez être content les effets
d'aubaine provoqués par certaines
filières ouais c'est tout
du climat qui nous attend pour elle
je peux juste sébastien genest c'est
très bien que toutes les propositions
tant premier commis je ferai partie de
ce que les écouteront avec beaucoup
d'attention voilà la rentrée des classes
ne manqueront pas celle qui s'annonce
donc âpre disputé parfois peut-être un
peu tendu chacune des formations
politiques devra s'afficher unie tiens
j'aimerais qu'on fasse le point sur
chacune des forces que vous représentez
commençons par la majorité
présidentielle avec le cas caroline
cayeux ministre délégué des est chargé
des collectivités locales on apprenait
dans le canard enchaîné hier que sacha
ou lié encore lui député renaissance
issu de l'ailé gauche et surtout
président de la commission des lois
avait refusé d'auditionner la ministre
lors de l'examen des ordonnances sur la
fonction publique territoriale en
polynésie française c'était quelques
jours après les propos polémiques de
caroline cayeux sur les lgbt ces gens là
comme elle avait dit elle répondait chez
nos confrères d'el cp sur ses positions
passées sur le mariage pour tous cette
question bruno myle yen est ce que la
majorité présidentielle est frappé de
comme celle culture
non moi je suis pas frapper quand cette
culture je condamne avec la plus grande
chance des propos de caroline cayeux
voilà j'ai rien d'autre a ajouté
sur une ordonnance qui n'a rien à voir
non mais d'avoir eu des propos qu'elle a
eu donc la plus droite s'exprimer sur
autres d'autres sujets non mais attendez
un petit a le droit de s'exprimer sur
d'autres pourquoi ça s'appelle l'a
empêché de ce que nous racontent nos
contrées du classement des attaches à
oublier mais c'est vrai que du coup
quelqu'un qui a réagi comme ça alors que
la cause lgbt et entendu les partager
par tous depuis longtemps oui ça gêne
beaucoup de monde dans la vallée où
vécut alors elle doit rester au
gouvernement
c'est au président de premier but si
sébastien jumel
moi je pense qu'elle est disqualifié et
c'est un pari majeur parce que dans le
même temps les communes peinent à
boucler leur budget dans le même temps
les communes sont confrontées à
l'ardente obligation d'être au chevet
des habitants les plus fragiles et dans
le même temps une réforme
de moyens à donner pour réarmer les
collectivités du quotidien sont au point
mort parce que la ministre n'est plus en
situation en état ont légitimité pour
porter quelconque réforme au sein même
de sa majorité
donc voilà lorsqu'on construit un
gouvernement
d'une manière
politicienne avec des doses
homéopathiques de conservateurs de reals
de libéraux de start hopper et bien on
aboutit cette absence de cohérence
politique alors sébastien jumel évaluons
les rapports de force à gauche également
la france un soumises organise une
grande rentrée à châteauneuf sur isère
près de valence 1 la semaine prochaine
dans la drôme avec de grands débats
organisés très médiatique un rachida
dati a accepté de venir comme marlène
schiappa ou encore clément bonne la
france a soumis chastel selon vous à
s'affirmer comme la seule véritable
grande puissance de gauche au détriment
de ses alliés de la nuque les
communistes ou encore les écologistes
écoutez la france en soumise est un
élément déjà les dires important
locomotive de l'opposition parlementaire
mais vous noté avec moi que ce qui a
fait la force de ce rassemblement c'est
sa diversité
et dans cette diversité
les parlementaires communistes
apporteront leur originalité et leur
singularité en étant profondément
attaché à la dynamique de rassemblement
créé mais en étant nous-mêmes mangement
notre propre basket en faisant sonner
notre propre musique
moi je constate que ce qui nous
rassemble au sein danube avec la france
quand soumise avec les socialistes avec
les écolos est plus fort que ce qui nous
distingue mais nous avons deux sujets
qui nous différencier c'est ce qui fait
notre richesse donc moi je je je je
pense que le fait que les journées les
universités d'été de la france ont
soumis square monde débat c'est bien
celle des communistes seront aussi
l'occasion
de débats on aura les uns et des autres
nous on est parlementaire on aura des
journées parlementaires une séquence
comme une je crois à la rentrée nous
allons continuer à
anneux pas éteindre j'allais dire les
les étincelle d'espoir créé par ce
rassemblement
si l'on veut s'opposer efficacement à
emmanuel macron et à sa mauvaise
politique il faut le faire en étant
unis mais aussi en étant force de
proposition c'est ce que nous allons
continuer à travailler à la rentrée faux
chacun
trouvé nos marques il faut le faire dans
le respect des différentes composantes
mais moi vous ne me trouverez jamais
tirant sur mes adversaires sur mes
partenaires de gauche où l'on tirait la
couverture et en
ses projets de liste commune également
pour les prochaines élections
européennes c'est pour ça que je vous
pose la question sébastien jumel un
rassemblement en est efficace que quand
ils additionnent des forces et non pas
quand il
les absorbent et donc c'est vraiment
l'addition de nos énergies qui crée la
victoire possible et je suis convaincu
que mes amis insoumise sont d'accord
avec ça merci beaucoup sébastien jumel
députés communistes n'eut pas de seine
maritime merci également à bruno myle
yens député modem des yvelines